hi everyone it's jerry this is game
six from the 2021 fiji world chess
championship match between magnus
carlson playing on the white end
and diane nyopomnichi going into game
six for level two and a half points a
piece in this race to seven and a half
there's a lot to this game
players were in bullet mode to meet
first time control blitz mode to make
second time control you can check out
the clocks
to get a feel for where the action
you know how down to the wire was
in this game
we set a record in this game for longest
game in world chess championship history
move wise
breaking a 124 move game that ended in
stalemate
in game five of the 1978 title match
between karpov and korchnoy
many imbalances in this one and at the
end of the day
it lasted about 7 hours and 45 minutes
there's a lot to unpack
let's hop in
d4 by carlson
we had d4 by carlson in game two
which was a catalan opening not quite a
catalan in this one though
it's considered a pseudo catalan after
both sides castle if white wants to
arrive at
a catalan opening if he wants to get to
a position
from game two he
can play c4
in this game instead it's b3
prepares to fianchetto and prepares to
have a pawn
there to recapture on c4
black strikes
the white center
and
white immediately resolves the tension
the idea behind this is to
take advantage of the unprotected bishop
on c5 so once c4 is in d takes c queen
c2
can't take on b3
lose the bishop so black defends that
white can pick this pawn up on c4 right
now but instead
uh
welcomes gambit play
so
knight b to d2 white would prefer to
take on c4 with the knight
and key in on the e5 square maybe even
have in mind knight a5
a knight on a5 can coordinate really
well with the bishop on g2
okay black doesn't
pursue
this pawn plus
he doesn't take on b3
if black captured on b3 the knight can
recapture bishop b6 is met
with the pawn advance keeps in mind uh
it also sets up a skewer
and if the bishop falls back here an
idea would be knight b
excuse me knight f to d2
opening up the bishop's eyes it's a bit
awkward for black to complete queen side
development
and this knight is ready to
hit the bishop on d6 it's a bit
uncomfortable right white is down upon
but has some nice queen side play queen
side pressure
instead black says i'm going to get on
with development knight c6 it is
pawn is recaptured
and
black
plays b5 so very sharp play
direct play
not just going one step going to
generating a threat
and vacating b7 for the bishop
now this is one of those proceed with
caution type moves the knight's now
hanging the rook is more accessible
what follows is knight c to e5
now if this other knight went here
the way out for black
is to play knight d4 hit the queen
and then follow up with bishop b7
white still has to worry about this and
the bishop is functioning well opposite
white's light square bishop
the move plate in the game is knight
seed e5 ducks this
and it's important now for black to
again avoid this knight exchange
if black captures on e5 this is a
problem for black the knight is getting
into c6 the rook is hit
big problem for black
in the game the best move was played
knight to b4
hits the queen and keeps a watchful eye
at least for the moment
over c6
now this next move is queen to b2 which
on the surface looks a little bit
awkward because normally you would want
to put that bishop there but
the reason that move is played is
because if let's say the queen goes to
b1
black's able to play bishop b7 and now
right around the corner
let's say after white tries to scare
away the knight with a3
this bishop can slip into e4 with tempo
it's quite timely
after the queen moves the knight gets to
move forward and this is uncomfortable
for white
having to work around this knight
deep in white's house supported by the
bishop
so
in order to avoid this possibility the
queen
takes up the post on b2
the bishop b7 follows the knight's now
given a kick and it must go backwards
c6 it is the knight exchange
is avoided for the moment hitting the
bishop
bishop b6
bishop g5 black gets on with putting a
rook on an open file
and white takes on f6 unprovoked
doesn't wait for h6
gets on with this
capture and
this is where things
really start to get interesting
normally if you're going to end up with
a damaged king site structure you'll
want to make sure the queens
are off the board but
this is
uh
i'd say ambitious play by black in
recapturing with the pawn keeping the
queens aboard
now this pawn does a good job in
controlling the knight
can't get to any of these squares but
what may be nearby
are moves
such as knight f4 knight h5
these are the big holes that are created
with this g-pawn
converted to an f-pawn
okay
this is considered a balanced position
after a queen exchange
i believe the follow-up computer was
suggesting b4 keying in on the c5 square
around even
king safety not an issue
in that in that position without the
queens
okay but in this game move 17 g takes f6
rook on a to c1 gets out of
any possibilities of a skewer
the bishop recapturing on d4
we do have the knight dive in
the bishop recapturing the queen has a
responsibility
there is pressure there
many exchanges now light square bishop's
off
king is exposed
uh f3 king g1
both were considered close to equal
there are pros and cons with each in the
game it's king g1
this allows the black queen to now take
up a very strong post in the center on
e4
quite the pest
this queen on e4
uh a benefit in playing f3 as you stop
queen e4 however
white would be giving up this big square
to the bishop on e3 and this can be
quite disruptive
so in the end
it's king g1
queen e4
queen c2
supports the knight
and after a5 we have rook f to d1
king g7
getting off of any
checks that may
happen on the back rank
useful move secures f6
it's a it's a nice king improvement
and after rook to d2
we have black go for an imbalance
rook a to c1
and
this this happens we have the two rooks
versus queen imbalance
and now black
uh
well even though white has the two rooks
versus the queen
there are these pawns over here that are
a bit vulnerable
white goes right after them
b3 is unprotected
so some pressure there
b4 is played
and it's important for black to
keep the a pawns around
plays a4
if black exchanges the pawns
this makes life much easier for white
because this knight
if we start at e2 e2 defends the knight
the knight defends the pawn
and we need only to
connect the rooks
it makes white's task much easier if
black captures on v4
it's a4 in this game and black clearly
has an eye on the a3 pawn
once this guy falls
this guy is very very dangerous
and was a
uh i think the main contributor in
carlson
ending up in serious serious time
pressure
i believe as both players were reaching
move 40 in this game
they were under a minute and there isn't
an increment
so that's all they had until that bonus
time hit at move 40 where they gain an
hour
and move 40. so
very tense game
e3 from here
the bishop e5 h4
i think the primary idea behind this is
not to play h5
uh i guess this could maybe be an idea
somehow the rook's circling back here
maybe this pawn controls a critical
square
at some stage but the the main one that
i'm seeing here is that a new square is
produced for the king
on h2
from here h5
k2 king h2 bishop
bishop to b2
i capture like this that would drop the
rook capture with the rook
that would drop the knight
doesn't go for that
instead the rook to c5 what's that move
32
about 10 minute advantage for
niupomnichi at this stage
this rook is hitting a lot of excuse me
this rook is hitting a lot of stuff the
queen
the pawns
the queen can't go too far either and if
this this bishop on b2 is hit twice if
the pin is no longer there along the d
file let's see say the queen goes here
we can take the we can take the bishop
so she stays on the d file
queen d6
rook d1
bishop takes a3 we have a passer so now
it's two rooks versus a queen in a very
dangerous pawn
rook takes b5 gets a pawn back queen d7
rooks c5 and only move
move 35
a lot of pressure on the clock e4 nearby
there's
e5 nearby there's e4
rook c2
queen d5
some coordination finally with these
rooks
the main the main
idea for white is to go after the apon
at this stage
so queen b3 rook a2
after e4 knight c5 that's move 39 queen
takes b5 and now right around here
in meeting move 40
you haven't have a look at the clocks
these are rough guys but it's it's close
to
this is right about where we were with
the clock times
um
this is where plenty of mistakes
occur in games and
in the game carlson
took the pawn on e4 this is not
considered best
uh
there is a
a nice
idea white could have
gone with at this stage rook on d
to c2 but again he only had
seconds so this is this is a ballpark
figure i think he had a little less than
a minute remaining as he played this
last move
knight takes
e4 rook c
rook d to c2 is
pretty cool
uh this bishop is frozen
this pawn can't move and this queen
cannot go too far
she has to stay
trained on this bishop
i guess maybe this one's an option you
can't take here because of that
but my point here is that the queen is
uh
pretty restricted well actually if the
queen goes there we simply pick up the a
pawn
so it's difficult for black in this
position if if white found this move
the follow-up idea the point behind rook
d to
c2 let's say f5 is played the point here
would be that white can now get rid of
the apon
and after this
we can reach a new imbalance
well a more simplified looking imbalance
no minor pieces and we have
once more two rooks
playing against the queen and this is a
super healthy kingside structure and
these guys here
will be
very vulnerable
to the rooks
form a battery on the fifth rank
and
watch over f2 this is the only point to
watch over this is going to be big
trouble for black
he didn't find rook d to c2 instead
knight takes e4
if you take the knight the rook would
take the pawn
and then soon this pawn
and play is
pretty simple from there
put the both rooks on the f-file and
these guys will all drop off while the
rook watches over the only sensitive
point f2
black understood this he does not bite
does not take that knight on e4
instead it's queen v3
and black is prepared
to put the pawn
on a3
only now two steps away
how do we get this pawn
white
first
repositions the pieces knight on f4 find
some secure squares
eventually
putting the rooks on the a file
this knight was also
maybe ready to grab on h5 so some
defensive move
for black
but how exactly do we get this pawn we
need the knight to reposition
and put pressure here so
starts off with
knight e2
knight d4
and
in this position the king goes back to
h2
if white in this position immediately
tries to go for the pawn with knight c2
this isn't the greatest because
let me let me make a passing move
let's say the king goes here
if
well i'm sorry let me make this move
right here the move played in the game
after after king h2
and
now let me get back right here
i will get this right
after knight to d2
uh knight to d4 excuse me
and king to h7 if white tries this move
uh
black can play
bishop here
and
there's a problem
this is the problem knight takes a3
can be met with
bishop takes rook
and after rook takes bishop
i think there's a better move than this
one but this one's clearest for me to
see
the queen on b3
kills this knight
where does it go
it doesn't have a move other than b1 and
the rook doesn't have a move other than
watching over the night
if the knight ever goes to b1
the queen's gonna be winning a piece
still though this would not be losing
for white
as difficult a position white is in
right now it's not losing
because
let's say after knight here and queen
to
b2
white would have a fortress
white can part ways with the knight
and
whatever black does next doesn't matter
this rook gets to f4
and i do not believe this position can
be broken down by black
this structure is too good
there is only one point to watch over
the rook or king can watch over f2
and how do you dislodge the rook
it can always maybe go to f3
f5
the king could jump around on g1 or g2
maybe even we have e4 in there and you
could play this i don't think this is a
a position that can be broken down so
it's something to bear in mind
this is this is a possible way out for
white
if he needs to go in this direction
so in the game it's king h2 queen e4
black is
allowing this pawn to be picked up
he has a threat
with this pawn pin the queen's ready to
take h4
uh he's okay with that
the number one problem for white is this
pawn on a3 so he takes that out and he
does this
you know white white plays this
being prepared to enter this particular
imbalance
where ideally
you want that rook again on f4 and
i think the idea would be you put the
rook on f4
you get this pawn to e4
and you get this knight to e5 excuse me
d5 and then you start hunting
these pawns one by one
this would be a very difficult position
for black to try and hold
i don't think black can be disruptive
enough to stop the rook from eventually
getting to the f-file
maybe
uh maybe we start well no not
not not here right away there can be
queen here
uh i'm not sure the exact setup maybe
this one trying to get this and this
that that that's looking like a good
start
try to get the the rook here and can
black even stop that
uh i'm not seeing a great way for black
to even stop that so it seems pretty
pretty clean way to get to f4
and then we go from there as well
okay tall task ahead for black
if they go in this direction in the game
black picks off the h pawn
there's a check king g1
another imbalance can surface here after
king g1
black played queen e4
if this is tried the capture on g3
and then this pawn starts to run
here's a cool variation e4
queen check king g1
and i'll just i'll just show one
variation after queen takes e4
here's how white can follow white will
win the queen
with the check
all these squares are covered the king
eventually has to go to f8
rook g2 check
rook h8 check
and in the end we have this skewer
supported by the knight
so this trick is not working that's not
the only variation but i cannot
uh i can't can't show them all i have to
pick and choose here in this super
lengthy game
okay in this and this one is queen e4
more repositioning queen is hit
the rook is hit
so queen there rook on
a1 to a2
staying
coordinated
uh white is the one playing for two
results especially now that that a pawn
is gone
uh these guys are vulnerable
so how to stay coordinated is the big
question for white
while also
trying to avoid perpetual checks
starts with f3 this safeguards the king
along the diagonal
at the same time it makes the king
vulnerable along the second rank
this knight for
some time from here is going to need to
simply be a babysitter for the king
shield the king from checks
we see plenty of nightmare
night maneuvers in this one
kicks off with f4 this not only
kicks the bishop to a square that
will be
well the bishop will be a bit more
vulnerable on any other any other square
besides e5 there isn't a
another square where black would have
pawn support so
it's a bit more vulnerable wherever else
it goes
also with f4 in there
f3 is vacant
for
this guy
and this square is made use of by the
knight
many times over
it's a it's a really good piece
defending against perpetual checks
so king f2 bishop b3
this now that f3 f4 is in e3 is
sensitive so
black keeps some pressure there with
first the bishop
now the queen is on that so
some defense is needed with rookie four
and let's get to an interesting point
here getting some maneuvers in
uh this rook is in a spot
to address this potential battery this
is one of the i i think the main idea
behind queen to b4
we don't want this queen
getting into e1
right if we don't do anything we're in
big trouble
here's a way we could get mated that
would be painful
so
it's rook c1 some defense
the rooks are well this rook is defended
they're not
the rooks aren't connected but then the
knight is helping out
uh to defend the rook on c1 so this one
isn't tactically vulnerable this is the
only one
from here rookie 5
queen b3
rook back
to e1
now in this position
there's a way that white can go wrong
attempting move for white in this
position is to say this pawn is a little
bit sensitive
let me attack it
big problem for white if he goes for
that
the problem here is that black would be
able to play f6
and where does this rook go
has a responsibility
doesn't have many squares
here or here the only ones
but the king can guard both one way or
the other
this rook is kicked
from defense of e3 and
big trouble for white
with e3 collapsing
this is not good tempting but not good
rookie 8 instead
queen d5
queen in the corner
rook back
a little repetition we do have some back
and forth going on in this game if queen
h2 the king can step up
if h4 we can capture this knight could
take up a nice post on g3
white would be winning from this
position
knight is an excellent defender of the
king there are no good checks
for the black queen
so
the queen gets central
black is doing a really good job this is
a difficult task
there are many different configurations
white can go with
black always has to
try and find a way to keep pressure on
white's position and make it
uncomfortable for white to coordinate
and so he's he's always trying to watch
over the e3 pawn
bishop gets away
we get on the fifth rank so now we have
some pressure on the bishop the pawns
indirectly
rook on the seventh
and now both rooks right with this last
move the queen no longer has defensive
b5 so now we're converging on f5
bishop a7
rook a5 group
back to b5
bishop a7 and now rook takes pawn so
with this move
uh
some calculation for sure
after queen d3
notice what's happening here
the queen is in a position putting
pressure on both rooks
if either one steps over to e5 to defend
the other one would be overloaded
so for example this guy here black could
take
and if you recapture like this there
goes that rook
and in this position if you step over
similarly we would have this chop
and then this one
and it seems to be uh
tending much more towards a drop
instead it's rook takes f7
entering
a new imbalance one where it is
uh a rook
knight in two ponds
versus a queen and pawn
well a rook knight and two pawns versus
a queen
these guys offset
these two highlighted pawns will soon be
exchanged
so
how to
coordinate your pieces is the big
question
for white we want to make sure we don't
end up in
we don't want to allow a perpetual check
very difficult task ahead for team black
a lot of different tries for white the
main one here being
to try and get the e pawn rolling
if this pawn could get rolling
you could start to see some progress
made by white
so how to stop
pawn to e4
we have a pin
all right from here rook c2 knight d4
some of these checks inserted i'm not
sure they have a great point to them
maybe they
you know
constantly giving checks like this black
has to make the decision do i move
forward or backward that's that can
sometimes be tricky
okay
another check thrown in knight back to
its favorite square there is no queen h2
knight g5 check
another check knight on d4 once more
rook in the spot to safeguard the king
in this case
and eventually white finds the following
setup
one that will help him
to advance the e pawn one step
so it's the night going back home
a lot of fancy night moves where 105
moves in
knight g1
and
now we have the knight getting to e2 and
by this point in fact right after rook
d4
this is where jan had a little bit of a
think how much time
maybe about a minute and a half
he knew what was coming for sure at this
stage with the rook on d4 he knew the
knight is going to shield
the king from any checks
look at this cozy home currently for the
king
there's no getting at him
and this knight defends the rook and
this rook defends e4 which means e4 will
be coming
and
a lot of squares will then be under
control
and it gets to be a little bit scary for
the black king
with this duo
that
can continue to move next once this pawn
is on e4
then maybe there's f5
or
e5
white has a pick
so the queen sticks around here on this
back rank still with an eye on h1 the e
pawn gets rolling
some check thrown in
other checks the h and g pawns are
exchanged and we're down to this
final imbalance rook and knight rook
knight and two pawns versus queen
this position right here is a draw
a table-based draw
computer versus computer game if if it
was a computer versus computer game the
game would be over
table base
draw
would be declared
and well
no these guys play like computers but
this is a very tall task
for black at this point
uh
a lot of problems still to solve
nearly an impossible task for black
great defense up to this point
let's see what follows let's see this
next setup white finds coordination in
the following way
the piece is doing a good job
in blocking the checks
and the plan here
is to recognize that the queen side of
the board
there's a lot of room for this queen to
maybe give checks so
uh the king has two
two ways you know he could try to circle
around like this
or he could go like this
and if he goes in this direction
uh the queen is going to be able to give
checks somewhere from a distance
but it's not so easy to do similar when
the king is on this side of the board
there's not as not as much space
for the queen
the king is
better off on the edge
in this case
there are no i files
j files so
it's the h file the king eventually
makes use of in this one
first the rook getting to an awesome
post
great coordination once more there's
only one unprotected pawn but at any
point there can maybe be a check here
here here
all of these pawns
well these two pawns are controlling
or supporting any of these rook moves so
this king
can be attacked in
all sorts of ways
so king e7 check another check now this
pawn advances
nice coordination nearby a rook on f6 if
we get that one in there
everything is defended
and the king can improve along the
h-file
from here king a2
king h3
this position is still considered a draw
by the table bases
there are about 20 moves in this
position
and only two of them
are considered to be a draw
queen b1
and i believe queen c2 i'm not 100 on
queen c2 i think queen c2 but queen b1
the main idea here being
to keep the the queen on the back rank
to be in a spot to maybe give a check
to maybe
go to this square and pin the knight if
the king is on h4 or if the king is on
g3 to go to g1 and pin the knight in
that way
to work along the first and second rank
the first rank
is is the main ring to be on here
in the game though we had
queen to e6 and now
this is considered a win
table base wise and
let's see how play continues reaching
move 30.
i didn't point it out that
once we reached move 125 that's where we
broke the record
but this one still continues for a
handful more moves
we do in this game end up getting to 136
the knight a convenient defender here
for the king
it's improved
nice synergy between the rook and knight
at this stage
uh the knight is within checking
distance so some tricks are right around
the corner
before the queen was doing a good job
staying at a distance but now
she's really close to the knight so
tricks are nearby
and we see one in action right now after
queen h7 e6
is the rook hanging
not really there's a trick
there goes the queen
and this is of course a one
position
so what's tried is queen to g6
from here rook f7 another trick
if this pawn is captured in this
position they would follow knight g7
knight takes queen we only have a pawn
but white is winning
this king and pawn ending wherever you
go you get out flanked
here once more you can get out flanked
and this pawn is ready to go
so after rook f7 we have
the king getting out of any knight
checks
white presses perfect coordination here
it cannot be broken down
after queen g1
we have the final move in this game
knight g7
and black resigns
what do you do here
if
we start giving checks on the h file and
g-file
the king simply zig-zags his way
all the way to
g8 and once he's on g8
there are no good checks
these pieces
uh shield the king from any checks and
note also
what the knight on g7 is doing it's
controlling the promotion square this
one's already under control
white is now ready to play e7
and next e8 with check no matter what
how might that play out let's just see
it in action
not really much you can do
eventually he gets here
and then here and what can you even try
this one we're pushing
and double check
yeah it's game over
anything else
queen here that's not working we're
winning
with this variation
knight supporting f6 king is supporting
f7 f8
game over in that variation
as well
so
160
excuse me 136 move games setting a
record
for a longest
a game move wise in world chess
championship history
exhausting
these guys played
an excellent game it was really tense uh
both players
under pressure
most pressure initially by
carlson was initially under the most
pressure meeting that first time control
was really really tense
if you were there during the live stream
you know it you felt it i know i felt it
um
what a game
that had a lot this was this was not
only the first decisive game of this
world chess championship match but the
first decisive game
in a world chess championship match in
five years
we've waited this long
for that breakthrough
so carlson now up three and a half
two and a half in this race to seven and
a half let's have a look at
the tail of the tape now this game was
so long
i needed two graphs
in order to show you
the tail of the tape so
let's get to it right here
this is the graph for the first
100 moves
the graph only
on leech has it only is able to show the
first 100 moves at the moment
so
here's the assessment of the first 100
moves
and we can
have a look at what the average senti
pawn loss after these first 100 moves
after move 100 by black queen h1
average centipond loss is
10 a piece
and moving on to the remaining 36 moves
there we go
uh
that's how it
that's how it went for the the rest of
the game right here was the last moment
after king h3
i believe i was saying queen b1 or queen
c2 or the only draws but
basically an impossible task at that
point
for team black who again put up
tremendous
resistance in such a tough tough
position
uh after queen e6 it was
you know that was that was the ball game
in the computer's eyes table base
draw was
no longer there
so those final 36 moves average senti
pawn laws for carlson 11 and 41
for nyopomnichi so
what a game uh we continue
um
i need to rest up that was a very long
game seven hours 45 minutes
it took for these guys to complete the
game so
look forward to game seven as usual feel
free to leave any feedback to this video
in the comment section below
hope you enjoyed it
and maybe took a thing or two or three
away from this
uh historical game
that's all for now take care bye
you